now right okay you ready
fine right okay right right i'll tell
them right all right okay no problem
i'm in it now four o'clock yeah right
okay i'll be ready to start sorry
counselor evan says he actually has sent
his apologies for the meeting because
he's got a medical appointment
right so here's an apology for the
meeting i've just phoned him he's on
he's just on his way for a scan so oh
okay rather more important than this to
be honest yes
yeah yeah okay well thanks welcome to
the uh meeting of the accounts and all
the committee on the 26th of november
uh item one is attendances i think we're
all present apart from
we've had apologies from councillor
evans and from councillor dylan
uh looking at my screen i think
everybody's
there who should be should be there so
item
two with a membership uh joe that i know
there have been some
changes yes chair they have
um as per the council of the annual
council meeting last night
um on this committee we've just
mentioned
councillor evans has come in to fill a
vacancy
and councillor thompson has replaced
councillor duffield
thanks welcome well rosie's here welcome
to rose and to uh nathan one of your
many appears i hope you enjoy the
committee we're here for the
rest of the municipal year hopefully
well item
three is uh terms of reference
who's is anybody going to take that is
it remarkable
just on that chair um that there's
actually been no change
since they they were last updated at the
start of the last municipal year but
because this is technically the first
meeting of this municipal year they're
just before the committee for
information
right can we just note those then from
unchanged from previous years
thanks very much item four questions
from members of the public joe have we
had any
we haven't yet surprised there you are
thanks for
that item five is minutes of the meeting
of 15th of july
for those of us who are there
free those thanks very much
agreed agreed thanks very much
item six the counter fraud and
enforcement team
update report that's david wright
actually i've not seen david's
is that you david at the bottom someone
has just
joined with an officer number yeah it
will be david
hello seven one zero nine zero
yeah that's me that's david all right
thank you
yeah okay you're on come back
all right okay
is it my um my item now yes
the update of the uh count of right okay
right thank you um well
so i'll talk about last year i think
first
um a bit of an update for this year
um you've all presumably had a chance to
digest the report that i've sent round
um in terms of last year it was very
much
the same in terms of the work we were
doing
a lot of the work we were doing in terms
of the fraud side was relating to
a council tax single person discount um
which the figures uh provided in the
report to show
that um based on um the reviews that
were undertaken
we'd identified just over 1200 uh
discounts that were removed
which created additional liability for
the for the authority
subject to collection would be just
under 450 000 pounds
and we had an agreement with the company
who did the review
on our behalf um as well as just doing
a simple review that we had a process
where
any responses to the review where there
was um
questionable whether they were actually
still eligible would be passed for
further investigation which is what my
team was looking into
um it made reference to um a case study
one which i think is on page
three of the uh report
where we talked about somebody who'd uh
responded to the review
saying yes they were still eligible for
the discount
um however there was quite a large
amount of credit data that had linked
an additional person an additional mail
to the property going back a number of
years
when she was questioned about it
initially she said that he'd
um he didn't live together and it was
you know
he was just using the address but on
further investigation
and further interview she actually
admitted that they've been
living together going back nearly nine
years
um and the discount was removed that
created
um additional liability over 2 000
pounds
and there was also a housing benefit
over payment as well that was linked to
that case
uh not significant amount but the same
housing benefit isn't our remit anymore
but there is still
uh clearly issues with that as well
quite often these things do overlap
um we'd also start about this time last
year it was actually
um we'd started doing work with
regarding small business rate relief
where we'd um
taken on some software from a company
that had identified
companies who were getting small
business rate relief
with trafford which would either reduce
or completely
take out their business rate liability
and
when they actually had all the
businesses elsewhere which would remove
that
entitlement uh which data matching that
we wouldn't otherwise have picked up
obviously we are dependent on what the
customer tells us
it's not data that would have been
otherwise available and we had some very
successful
um cross authority
matches with that so what we'd find is
the businesses involved would be
claiming the small business rate relief
in the other authorities
and who we wouldn't normally be working
with
so we had some very effective results
and say as a result of that
we're able to generate additional
liability on a number of accounts
um a large part of the work that we and
then this is
this is an area uh if we look at uh 2.4
of the report a large part of the work
we've done
has been working closely with the subway
care because obviously social care
debt social care finance comes under
extracurricular services
the team the financial assessments team
and we work quite closely now with the
social workers
and the direct payment audit team um and
what we found
and unfortunately it's a continuing
theme of where
customers um and of course these these
the
service users are having their uh
finances abused
sometimes unfortunately by members of
the f their own families
who are actually supposed to be absent
in their interests
and last year this was a case i was
quite heavily involved in myself
which is the one i've talked about in
case study two
um it was a young young male a young
teenage male who
quite clearly um had quite heavy autism
um issues and we were paying
giving money which was there for his
support for his care
uh and for his education and
unfortunately his family
and so i'd say his own parents um
abused that position and what we found
was that the money was being transferred
so it wasn't
not only was it not being used for his
care or support on the care plan that
had been set up for him
and the money was being diverted into
various bank accounts belonging to
members of his own family
um from that we identified
just over 21 000 pounds had been
misspent
uh by doing that over a three year
period
um and as a result of that we actually
did prosecute
the the father of the of the child uh
and that it was in the mainstream menus
you may have seen it
um and that resulted in the father being
given a nine-month custodial sentence
albeit suspended for 12 months and
thankfully there although the support is
still there
for uh the child um
the parents know no longer have access
to those funds
um so we can more clearly spend and make
sure the money is spent on what it's
supposed to be for
um so that in terms of the fraud work um
that was that was the main
the main um work that we did i mean i
have broken down
a table there in table two uh which
shows through the different areas of
work
council tax discounts council tax
exemptions councils have support
and various council tax related issues
business rates
and the social care finance and an
internal state a case
that we generated just under just over
227
000 pounds for the authority
um and of course the team is split into
two it's not just counter fraud the
other side is the litigation which now
comes under
my team and as you can see from there um
these are mainly social care debt again
and it's money that has normal um
recovery processes have been unable to
uh i don't recover the monies
um but by using the litigation process
or at least the threat of the litigation
process
and using mediation working more closely
with the
say quite often it is family members or
their representatives
um we've been able to recover quite some
significant amounts and you see from the
three the table there
this this amount is going up as social
care debt is continuing to go up
and so is the money thankfully that
we're able to recover
so in terms of what we achieved last
year
um that was what we did
now i probably sat here this time last
year
um planning what were we going to do
this year
and i think probably like for the rest
of us those plans have
gone out the window um somewhat um
i think it's fair to say that our
uh activity has been spent a large part
of it on other things
so i did have a plan um
which as you can see in section 5.1 to
talk about what we were going to do
which was
to do carry on what we were doing
already in relation to the
revenues various revenue streams that
our service covers council tax business
rates adult social care
we would we've already set up or made
plans to continue with a single person
discount review
and there's the national fraud
initiative data matching exercise which
we work closely with
mark's audit team um
we would do um that of course kobe came
along
and we've had quite heavy involvement
in the grand scheme that initially of
course we did
uh in march april may um we put a small
team together
um from other areas of the service
and some of mark's audit team were
involved in that as well
um just got some figures there
we processed this is today this is the
scheme from the lockdown back in the
spring
um just over 43 and a half million
pounds worth of grants were paid out
um and of course we just about started
getting things back to normal
um a lot of that and this is probably
something i'll be talking about next
year
uh is investigations into some of those
grants there's been you know some quite
significant amounts just
unfortunately with any scheme which is
there to help people there will be
people
who will look to abuse it and we have
had
instances of that a lot of those
investigations are ongoing
i can't really report on them at the
moment i mean that's not necessarily
money for the authority of course but it
is
the public person we have a duty to
investigate
it and then of course we've got the um
the current lockdown and the current
restrictions the new grant scheme
which we've been uh administering and so
far
obviously this is ongoing uh we've paid
just over 1.8 million pounds out it's
it's a lower
amount lower businesses that lower
number of businesses that are eligible
for it
but it's a lot more complicated scheme
because the rules are a lot stricter
and obviously as of today's announcement
um we're going to be working on
restrictions for a little bit longer
anyway so
i see that work continue certainly until
the new year
at the very least and then that will
impact it's not impacted on
the recovery work we've done the
litigation although as a service we did
suspend recovery for a long period of
time
we've still managed to cover quite
significant amounts but certainly in
terms of the fraud investigation work
and generating money for the authority
um there will be
a knock-on performance on our
performance for next year but i say
that's because we've been doing other
things
um and in a nutshell that that is in
what we've done and what we've been
planning to do
so i'll open the opportunity if anybody
wants to
uh ask any questions yeah thanks david
any questions from
from members rose is that
you have to unleash
thanks for that report i thought it was
really interesting and i did like the
case studies because he kind of
brought it to life and made it more
understandable
just a quick question about going
forward and the
business support grants that you will be
investigating
does that cover the discretionary grants
or is it just the
business support grants we've only been
involved with the
business support grants the initial ones
that were done in
march and april the discretionary ones
they came under strategic growth
we did help them with that and we
certainly worked with them on queries
with that um not i can't think off the
top of my head we've done any
investigation into those grants
but certainly in relation to the
business support grants yes
there's been was quite a lot there thank
you
thanks ross okay anybody else
so uh councillor wynn stanley
yeah thanks chair uh yeah also
fascinating report
i've gotta say um yeah just just a a
couple of
uh a couple of questions you partially
answered i think in
uh as you were summing up uh when you're
looking at
um who you choose to investigate in the
small business we need you send us some
software which quite cleverly identifies
people who have businesses outside of
trafford
and who are um frozen they claim this
ball business so we understand why you
you arrive at those people to
investigate
when you're looking at direct payments
or single person discounts
did you do an audit to everybody over
there specific people who
were flagged up in some way to go and
investigate
the direct payment ones we would based
off
um referrals from the direct payment
audit team so it's stuff that they come
across when they're doing their audits
right um the single person discount uh
that is
a it's again based on data matching it's
mainly credit based data
so the we would submit the data to the
company that's doing it on our behalf
um and only the people who get the
reviews are the ones where there's
hits so you know you have somebody who
for our attention purposes
is supposed to be living alone what the
credit data is linking an additional
person to the property so they're more
targeted
so the referrals we work on them are you
know they are targeted but they're
because we have reason to suspect that
the discount may be incorrect
okay that makes that makes more sense
and there was a second question that's
okay
and it is to do about with the the
planned activity around kobe 19.
um because did you say you'd already
started to investigate
um issues of potential fraud for the for
the code with 19 grand or that's
something that you're it's part of the
plan
no we have been um in terms of the the
scheme that was
the lockdown scheme earlier this year
yes we're
still working on we have identified a
number of cases already
and we was we were working on them
ongoing but of course
that's kind of everything's kind of
fallen by the wayside at the moment
because
we're dealing with it with the current
scheme and i've been landed with that as
well so
we've which i guess is
follow-up question the follow-up
question is because the worst things are
complicated
gives an opportunity for both accidental
fraud which if that
does not exist legal i suspect not about
the actual fraud so
i'm wondering if that's the work you've
done so far you come across people
you've made you've genuinely been
confused by this
by the um by the schemes as opposed to
deliberately trying to defraud the
system
yeah well there's been examples of both
to be honest
um you know because the scheme you know
it's a new scheme a lot of people didn't
know
what the rules were and sometimes it it
was
done incorrectly it's like with any um
overpayments we identify
but we have also come across things that
are quite blatant where people
uh i'll give an example one that i've
dealt with myself where
somebody had been able to access our
empty properties data which is there for
open
is there opening for people to see and
provided a false lease
to say that they were occupying a shop
um in altering them town centre
and claimed the grant got you know the
company
details of companies house and for what
all intents and purposes appeared to be
genuine application
um but it wasn't the the genuine owners
knew nothing about this person the
property had been empty and it remained
empty for some time is
so and that person that had taken a 25
000 pound grant
based on that application uh but this is
the problem when
you know that we're under a lot of
pressure to pay out these
these kind of monies and not everything
whilst we did have a
checking and verification process people
you know we're able to work around it
yeah and i guess when you when you get
the when you discover
um that mistakes have been made then you
make a decision whether you prosecute or
not i guess
if it's clear because the people have
made a mistake you just get the money
back don't you
i'm assuming yeah i mean the the initial
um thing because
again we've been restricted about what
we can do um
whereas normally you'd you'd have a case
that you may
consider where there has been a
deliberate fraud and you'd be doing
face-to-face interviews what we've not
been able to do them for obvious reasons
uh i think we've done one i did one a
couple of weeks ago where we had a
kobe process where we've done one so far
so we've not been able to do that
it's been more about correction and
recovery
um you know rather than prosecution
that's not to say we won't do any yeah
at the moment there's still cases
ongoing
that's brandon's great thanks jim thanks
barry
anybody else i can't see anybody no well
thanks
david for that you you're not forced to
speak the rest of the meeting but it's
very interesting report
okay thanks very much all right bye-bye
thanks
thank you next item is item seven which
i think
my ipod has died on me item seven is the
early completion report which is mazars
is it
karen or tommy you're going to do that
i'll start if i nurture but if members
have got any really difficult questions
i will as i always do
and hand them over to tommy because he's
much better at the technical detail than
than i am if if that's okay so
the um the audit completion report that
you have before you brings together
um really all of our work for the for
the year on the council's accounts and
the vfm conclusion
it is a fairly long report of that i
apologize
um it's because we need to report on
those two things and we also need to
report to you on
uh the requirements uh around
professional standards on things like
fees and independence and so on
um the audit unfortunately isn't yet
complete
um we received the accounts in mid-july
and i think it's probably fair to say
that it's been really challenging
for uh both the councils taymandos um in
preparing accounts and
auditing them in a lockdown situation
and we are very grateful to the finance
team for all of their efforts the
accounts were prepared to good quality
at standard and were supported by good
working papers and we have had continued
at support and and responsiveness
throughout the process
but obviously it is more difficult when
uh neither we know you are in the
building as it were
and it isn't just much more difficult to
get some of the assurances that we need
and so that that has been particularly
challenging and i will come back to that
later on um i hope that we will be in a
position to
issue an unqualified audit opinion on
the accounts but
that is subject to us being able to
finish the outstanding work
um just in the context of that
unqualified opinion
i do need to explain though that we will
be including an emphasis of matter
in the uh council's audit opinion
relating to material valuation
uncertainties in respect to property
planting equipment
investment properties and the council's
share of
pension funds property assets too
so i just want to deal with that bit
first and then we can i can talk through
the rest of the report
because um i want members to be
absolutely clear
that this is an accounting issue it's
not about anything that anyone has done
wrong
um it's not that there is a fundamental
problem
and what has happened is that um because
of the
uh corbett pandemic and the lockdown at
the end of march it's become much more
difficult to get the valuation of assets
um at the 31st of march so valuers
um were issued with guidance from their
uh professional body the royal institute
of chartered surveyors
which essentially said that when they
issue a valuation report for the 31st of
march
they should make reference to that
circumstance and suggest that the
valuation
whilst it's their professional judgment
is probably a little more uncertain as
an estimate than they
have been in previous years um
and we will need to draw a reader's
attention to that if you like in terms
of the order opinion
because it's important that people
understand the limitations that are on
some of those numbers
in the aims we
expect to issue an unqualified value for
money conclusion
sorry we expect to wish you a qualified
value for money conclusion
because you are still in the position of
having the um offstage report on on
children's services which didn't rate
your services
the level that you or i would want them
to be
um just going through the report you'll
see there's a list of work that's
um not complete in there and it might be
helpful if i just update where we are
with that because actually some of it
has moved on since this report was
drafted and issued
so the work on property plants and
equipment valuations and
investment property valuations isn't yet
finished
um it's important to understand that
that's partly be well mainly because
we've had difficulty in getting
information from the valuer
we started this work back in uh july
and actually i've only really received
information in the last
few weeks unfortunately the amount of
work that we need to do on valuations
and the evidence that's provided by the
valuer
means that all of that takes some time
and we are working really hard to get
through it as quickly as we can
we have as it stands at the moment
identified some errors in the
information from your valuer
so um i'm not in a position to talk
through these in detail yet because we
haven't agreed all of it um
with the value and with the council but
give you an example and there is a
school
that is included in your balance sheet
where the valuer had missed an entire
block
from the valuation and therefore the
valuation was understated
um by several millions of pounds but
when we extrapolate that across the
whole population it becomes a
bit more significant an issue but
equally and just to give you some
reassurance we have found some errors
that go the other way as well
where calculations and the evidence that
the valuer calculation errors that the
valuer
has made in the information that he's
relied upon
that means that things are overstated as
well so there are some some numbers and
others and i hope
that we will end up it's not a material
adjustment
we are waiting for the valuer to confirm
um our
view of all of all of that and come back
with us come back to us on it but it is
very likely that your accounts will need
to be amended the report refers to the
pension fund work
still being outstanding so that's the
working respect of your defined benefit
liability
that's now substantially complete
actually and subject to clearing a few
review notes
that's finished um there is an issue
with
cash and cash equivalents you might
recall we had a similar problem last
year
there are two bank confirmations that
are still outstanding at the moment
and they are confirmations due from the
banks of individual schools
um i think it's probably uh fair to say
that we asked for that information some
time ago
the school didn't respond because of the
initial lockdown
subsequently the requests were
variously either incomplete completed
incorrectly
or um deleted because they thought it
was a scam which to be fair to them is
is probably um not an unreasonable
position to be in
but the unfortunate problem with these
automatic confirmation systems is that
we don't find out that the bank is
rejecting the request for the
confirmation
until the end of the 28-day period so
that's been particularly problematic
but officers are trying to help the
schools to expedite that matter
um the report then goes on to talk
through all of the significant risk that
we identified and that we reported to
you when we brought our audit strategy
memorandum um
i'll not go through them in massive
detail because i've
talked about some of them already but um
in terms of property plans and equipment
you'll see there our work is still
outstanding but there will be the
material valuation uncertainty opinion
potential liability our work is now
complete but there is the issue about
the pension fund's
share of uh property um assets
we've looked at the airport shareholding
you'll be aware that it has
gone down significantly the 31st of
march 2020 compared to the previous year
our work on that is complete and we're
happy that that's fairly stated
our work on pfi is now complete and
there are no matters to bring to your
attention in terms of your accounting
for pfi schemes
and our work on schools is also complete
so there's nothing we need to bring to
your attention there
we did of course during the course of
the audit have to discuss a number of
issues with
uh your finance team and management so
the impacts have covered on the
council's functions and finances the
internal controls that you were
operating and so on
whether or not the council remains a
going concern in light of particular
financial challenges that are faced
because of course you pay your accounts
on a going concern basis
and then some issues arising from some
legal cases in respect to pensions that
have arisen during the year
the report um we are required to comment
on particular difficulties that we've
had during the
audit and the only thing that we mention
is the the problems that we've had in
getting hold of
uh evidence from your valuer you will
see that we've made a number of
internal control recommendations
actually there's relatively few
um but the first one i guess is a little
bit frustrating really because it
relates to valuations and i think we
raised
an internal control point last year we
know that your finance team did an awful
lot of work to try to address this
situation following on from the last
year's audit but unfortunately it didn't
really get us to where we needed to be
in terms of the extent to which we're
expected to challenge
um the information relied on by your
valuer
um the other internal control
recommendations relate to
your disclosures around your financial
instruments and then around your leases
we have made amendments to the accounts
in respect to both of those things but
it's probably just worth me
stressing to you that their disclosure
amendments they don't alter
the council's reported financial
position
um there's just one unadjusted
misstatement in your account so that's
at the moment that's just one thing that
we found that
um uh you haven't amended but which is
an error and that relates to a
misclassification between
cash and creditors um not particularly
significant but we are required to
report it to you because of the value of
it
and you will see that we're referencing
and adjusted
misstatements in your accounts as well
um that
relates to the pension liability i think
it feels a little bit harsh for me to
classify that as an adjusted
misstatement because
actually what the council chose to do
was get better and more accurate
information from the pension fund
and to reflect the passage of time since
the 31st of july
and then to reflect that better and
updated information in your
account but because you'd already used
draft accounts i need to report it to
you as
having been amended so that you're clear
that they can't change from the first
draft you saw to these
and you will see as well listed in the
report a number of changes that we've
made
in respect to disclosures um i'll stress
again that none of those have any impact
on the primary statements or the
council's reported financial position
they are amendments that are really
intended to drive improvements in
accountability
and court compliance so and in theory
hopefully make your accounts
uh more straightforward and easier to
understand um
and i say that without laughing really
because obviously local authority
accounts are very long
and complex documents it is quite a
longish list
of amendments but there's nothing in
there that is particularly significant
or that you need to be
particularly concerned about that's all
the issues in respect of the accounts
i'm just going to move on to talk
about value for money for a couple of
minutes if i can and then i'll
take any questions that members of the
committee have got
so in terms of value for money there
were two risks the council's financial
resilience financial position
um and the uh children's services
service and the ofsted report the latter
of those
leads us to a qualified conclusion again
for the year
but in terms of financial resilience we
have not
made any recommendations or qualified
our vfm conclusion
and i just want to take a few minutes to
kind of rehearse that and explain why
so it's important to bear in mind that
the arrangements that we are looking at
the arrangements that were in place for
the council for the financial year
2019-20
and of course as we sit here now in
november 2020 that financial year that
started
uh in april 2019 feels like it feels a
lifetime away in terms of how the world
has changed
um for 1920 you had it you had sets of
dollars budget
you had identified where you had
additional funding coming in that you
could utilize to provide services
you'd identify some reserves that you
needed to apply to support your services
but you'd also identified some areas of
savings that you needed to make and you
had
at the start of the year and for most of
the year all the way through very robust
arrangements in place for monitoring
your actual position
against that budget and reporting it so
at any point in time the council was
absolutely clear about where its
financial pressures were
what they were and why they were arising
and what mitigations could be taken to
address that and to bring the position
back
into balance and that's why at the end
of the year you delivered
the surplus a small surplus which is
probably where you always
expected to land if you like despite
what were significant uh spending
pressures in both your adults and
children's services
as well as that during 2019-20 you were
able to set a balanced budget for 2021
um and you did that um earlier on the in
the year
and you updated your medium term
financial plan to 2023
and setting out this the uh council's uh
financial plans if you like it a fairly
broad level
um right the way through that you took
in setting that balance budget and
updating the financial plan
you took account of all of the right
things so you've got
information in there it was your best
assumption around local government
finance settlements
you've got assumptions in there around
pay and price inflation which were
perfectly reasonable
you'd allowed for the demand pressures
that you thought you may not be able to
manage and would otherwise need to fund
you'd allow for some investments that
you wanted to make and some
use of reserves to support your services
you'd also identified the need to make
some savings
and you'd recognize the need for savings
at different levels all the way through
to 2022-23
work was underwear to deliver savings in
this financial year the 2021 year
and you were also on track and working
hard
uh to identify the serving savings plans
that you could bring forward for the
subsequent years in that
mediums home financial strategy and i
think it's fair to say that um
right the way through the financial year
to march 2020
everything in the council's arrangements
was going well and um
under control but of course in march
2020 the world
rather tilted onto a slightly different
axis and started to spin in a different
direction
i think is probably the best way to
describe it um
there is of course a significant
financial pressure now arising from the
pandemic
and the council is having to provide
additional services that were not
uh provided before particularly for the
vulnerable in our communities
and you have you have faced additional
demand for your services from
both adults and children services in
particular but other areas as well
and of course perhaps most importantly
you've had a significant
drop in the income that you can expect
to
secure during the year so that is the
impact of the lockdown on
fees and charges um particularly on
collection rates for casal tax and
business rates and of course the airport
dividend
so all of that gives you a really really
challenging and very difficult financial
position to manage
and i know that i'm not telling you
anything new here
but i do need to make clear to you that
in my view whilst reserves will help you
to get through the position
in 2021 they are not alone it's not a
long-term sustainable position to expect
to be able to rely on reserves to
support service provision you are going
to have to find
uh and make permanent reductions in your
cost base
in order to remain financially
sustainable and i think it would be
remiss of me to
comment on financial sustainability
without recognizing that that position
all of that aside i think as as members
of the council you can take comfort from
the fact that the arrangements you have
in place to monitor
and understand and plan your finances
are robust
um they are effective and at any point
in time uh your finance team will be
able to tell you how things are going
uh you know and where actions need to be
taken
the challenge of course is making sure
that those actions are taken quickly
enough
and are significant enough to make the
difference
that's all i was going to say the rest
of the report
is um the the things that were required
to report under professionals undersaw
information on independence and so on
and i wasn't going to
labor any of any of that because i'll
take it as read by members but
i'm happy to take any questions
hello thanks any any questions for
anybody
marywin stanley councilman stanley
yeah thank you chair and thank you for
um
karen for summarizing that extremely
lengthy report
um because two non-accountants that's
that's
really really helpful really helpful i
just want to return to this evaluation
i'm asset because that's quite critical
isn't it to
any organization's finances and some of
the notes i made when reading the report
you referred to when you were
uh you were you were going through the
the summary that you gave um
because there's the reference made to
some material valuation uncertainty
that's
that's that's to do with the the
uncertainty around kobe 19 in the fact
that
asset value has changed graham's not
that i'm more than happy to discuss
this later on the agenda grave that
makes more sense rather than
it it's really trying to graft towards
that when when would that massive
uncertainty be resolved and
how is it resolved because we've got
we've got acid companies
by these are assets so will we get
involved in a matter of negotiation with
them as to
as to what the assets are actually worth
because that question makes sense
it does make sense and i'm i'm going to
try and answer it with
reference to an example if that's okay
so that i can try and
be clear about what the situation is so
um if you think about it in terms of
your own house
and the problem with valuation of your
own house is it's
it's worth what you think it's worth but
if you get three estate surges in
they'll come with three different
numbers when you come to put it off sale
they'll give you three different prices
and you'll pick one you like but
actually the true value of your house is
what a buyer will pay for it
so a valuer a bit like an estate agent
if you like comes along and estimates
what they think something's worth
based on all of the information
available to them including their
understanding of the market
but actually the best estimate is what
what somebody will pay if they wanted to
buy it the valuer is trying if you like
to estimate what that figure
is the problem in march is that there
weren't any transactions going on so
if you if you think about it if you sold
your house on the 28th of february
it was probably worth a figure and if
you sold it at the end of april it was
probably worth the same amount
but in march you'd have struggled to
sell it so you could
make the case i guess that the asset
didn't have any value in march
that your house had no value on the 31st
of march but that's not true
it was a just a timing issue does that
make sense
so what what the material valuation
uncertainty does it says
we we believe these values to be
materially correct and i'm satisfied
based on the work that we've done
and subjects that we're still completing
issues we've identified
that that's right there is evidence for
the way in which the value has arrived
at that valuation
the valuer though is required to say but
you know what it was march 2020 the
world had gone a little bit crazy who
who knows really
um and that's what the material
valuation uncertainty does
the other thing i just want to mention
is that the valuation of assets in the
local authority
context is a little bit different um
than it might be
in lots of other in lots of other ways
because actually
for the majority of your assets so
everything that is your operational
london buildings there are
there are two things to say the first is
you are not trying to sell them or raise
the funds
um that they are holding your accounts
for
and because you're delivering services
from them and the second thing to say
uh is that you're also not trying to
borrow money against that value so
you're not trying to mortgage them
but the other side of that is that um
in a way the valuation doesn't really
matter either
because if the value goes up or down you
don't reflect that up or down through
your accounts
and that sits in your revaluation
reserve
in order to make sure that your council
tax doesn't need to go up or down each
year
as the value of your assets uh increases
or decreases
so this is really about a niche bit of
accounting that doesn't
much matter um to the council tax payer
but i'm going to hand over to graham if
he wants to add anything on the back of
that because
he might take us like different view
about some of the assets particularly
the investment properties
where it is important that you do know
and understand the values
yeah because you're just too common
that's the bit i've missed completely is
that
i'm used to value an asset asset for
what they're worth
so yeah at some point you might want to
sound a bit i was missing i think was
the fact of course it's obvious when you
stop and think about
it you're not going to you're not going
to sell the town who are you
well that's right in normal times you're
not going to sell the turnover
yeah thank you i think
graham yeah thanks karen for that
explanation and
um and thanks for the question i think
i think what i'd just like to add is
that this
concept of material uncertainty is not
just
relevant to traffic it's all local
government so we've all had that
and i think what the expectation will be
is that obviously
we do valuations every year and we need
those valuations to be caught up
so we can present a position hopefully
at the end of
march 21 that's that's not subject to
this material uncertainty
caveat i think i
i think the area of concern biggest for
us is is the valuations
around the investment properties
particularly the properties we've bought
through the asset strategy um
and and we do go back to the fact that
well what did we buy these assets for we
bought these assets for
long-term income streams in most cases
so a short-term impact on valuation is
not something that we would
react to with the knee-jerk reaction i
think what we're more concerned about
is the is the reliability of the
strength of that income stream from the
tenants who's occupying that property
and that's what we've been monitoring
and that's that's the short-term impact
on on the
on the um on the budget that we're
really concerned with at the moment
that's not to say valuation doesn't come
into play and the value of the balance
sheet
can't be understated and we do look at
that because at the end of the day
we've got debt on those properties and
we've got to work out what to do with
that debt
if if it's a prolonged and sustained
reduction
so what we will do this year again is
get revaluations for those assets
and take stock where we are do we know
what this stage where we'll be i think
the values would still struggle given
the market uncertainty which
we've got but perhaps in two or three
months time
it might be different so
yes i just just come back on that and
i'm sorry if i didn't make clear and
thinking back on it i didn't make clear
that the material valuation uncertainty
applies across the sector and it applies
to more
uh organizations than it doesn't there
are relatively few
who won't have a material evaluation
uncertainty reflected
all the opinion does is reflect the
things that are already
in your account so you've already
recognized it and just drawn attention
to it in my report
yeah i think i did i didn't actually get
the point but the one that i did it did
understanding all of this was
that the material valuation uncertainty
is it's across the piece isn't it it's
not it's not just traffic it's not just
local authorities
thank you brilliant thank you
anybody else any questions sorry chris
yes cancer boys
well yeah i might miss this i know
obviously you're not complete
do you actually have in your mind an
estimate of a date when you're going to
complete
the account um it depends
very much now on two things really one
is the response to
the uh from the banks to the bank
letters that are outstanding the bank
confirmations and then the other one is
the
the timeliness of the responses from the
valuer um and then us being able to turn
that revenge
and you be able to reflect any
amendments that required in the accounts
so i would hope not too much longer um
and we are
still working really hard to try to make
sure that that is monday
i just not in a position at the moment's
guarantee that that's the case
because those two response things are
outside of my control
right because when the theoretical
deadline is it's monday isn't it
yeah right yeah
okay nobody else i can't see anybody
else putting the hand up
okay thanks very much for that karen
you can stay for the rest of the meeting
if you want thank you
i'm very generous in that respect yeah
right on to the next item which is item
um eight the 2019-20 annual governance
governance statement which i think uh
dominique cites from our legal section
is going to take
dominic
um yes um so the annual
governance statement is um as say
a lengthy document um it is in a similar
format to what you've had in previous
years um and obviously in respect of
each areas there we have the risks
um outstanding um i don't propose to go
through the sections of the report in
any day
great degree um you have had hopefully
the opportunity
to consider that and what i will do
instead is
um offer any questions
at this point or any comments and i will
do my best to answer most of them
if not i may look towards mark foster um
to pick those questions up with me
thanks very much are there any questions
for anybody
looking around no i think dominique i
think you've
got away with that lightly i think there
so
one thing that one thing i will um add
chair is
last last time round i do believe there
may well have been
um some questions around ig
um and i just i i can outline them
for you at the moment um and um
perhaps add some detail if further
information is needed
so i believe last time there were some
questions
around um ig service generally
uh the progress that had been made um in
respect
of um meeting time scales with regards
to
fois and sars i also believe there may
have been some
questions around data breaches specific
data breaches
and possibly more information there and
also
i believe there was a request for just
general
information really around data breaches
and you know things like how many we get
how are they recorded what do they
uh entail that type of thing so i'm just
wondering if anybody would like me to
pick up on in any of those
questions specifically yeah i think i
forgot about that we did ask about
data breaches because uh without any
details being given
i think there were three or four
reported last time
i know we can't discuss exactly what the
data breaches were but if we could
if you could give us some a broad
picture about what's been
done to prevent those i'll be helpful
yeah so i i guess the um the answer to
the first question which was around what
what what's the id team doing uh with
regards to fois
sars and that type stuff kind of ties
into what i'm going to say around the
data breaches so
the two data breaches which were
previously reported to you
obviously as you've mentioned i can't go
into the detail too much they are
subject to ongoing legal claims at the
moment
but what i can say is that the two cases
were very very similar in terms of
circumstances
and they involve personal data being
included within documents
and distributed to external parties
inappropriately so
in terms of our usual process they were
reported to the ig
team they were then dealt with by the
dpo
um andrew van dammes and then they were
taken up to our cyro jane
further they were reported there from to
the
information commission officer and
the ico has been in regular contact with
us since they have actually confirmed
that they don't
intend to take any formal action
against us they don't necessarily
qualify
why um they do um ask
for reassurances from us around what
we've done uh going forward um
to one mitigate the risks of that
particular didn't stay
to incision incident and also whether we
can identify
ways in which we can change our
processes and practices
so um on the back of both
of those um
[Music]
incidents um we started to look at
how they had come about um and what we
could do going forward
now you may be aware that we have
actually initiated back in july this
year
um an ig project the ige project
is effectively a service review um
and it's a real back to basics on the id
service which looks at what they do
how they do it how we can make
improvements going forward
um what are the areas of risk for the
council and how do we approach that
um so the ig project team have been
working tirelessly
uh since july and what they're doing is
pulling together an overall project plan
which we're actually
six months in now just reviewed and
refocusing objectives
and resources what you'll see
there is that they have been
concentrating on the backlog
of subject access requests
as a priority and they've undertaken a
lot of tasks
simple things like all the documentation
was on hard copy
that's now all being scanned into the
system so it's all electronic
which obviously helps us all working at
home now it means the ig officers can
actually progress them a bit quicker
we've introduced a software reduction
which is a lot safer than doing manual
reductions etc
they've introduced the rag rating now
all subject access requests are rag
rated
and that has led the team to be able to
come up with a really focused plan
of approaching the stars and that's a
two-way approach they will
approach the backlog and they will
approach the incoming that we have
at the moment um they also have targeted
resources now
so certain members of this team which
are now complemented by two additional
uh id officers are actually working on
are on that um
and that's that's what they focus on on
a day-to-day basis
so um alongside that we team have been
doing
lots of other things um reviewing the
the foi process for example
um we're doing things like introducing a
case management system
and it's the same case management system
that legal team use so
it tracks it for audit purposes from the
incoming outgoing
um sends out updates all the usual
things you would expect from a case
management system
um they've also been looking at data
breach policy reporting
and they've linked that into hr so we're
near to
having a new procedure which we will
release
which um is really clear for officers
around who's expected to do what when a
data breach
occurs um and also who's responsible for
mitigating the circumstances following a
breach
and as i said it also now will link into
hr in terms of they will have a role
potentially for the more perhaps serious
data breaches
for their bit to be a disciplinary
process linked into that
an investigation so a lot of works
happening
um we are as i say refocusing on our
objectives going forward
the aim being now that we've had a good
run into the id project and we've got a
real good idea of what
our objectives need to be going forward
and there is
a currently discussions around
additional resources needed
we are pitching for those resources on
the basis that actually
um we still need to cover the star
backlog
um and we're projecting a march
deadline so march 21 in terms of
having got through the style backlog
and made significant progress around
other um
key priorities for for the igt
um and um what we're hoping to do is a
report has been drafted
and once um that report is finalized in
terms of signed off by
um ciro and clt and it'll go through i
believe the information assurance board
it will then be in a a format which can
be shared more widely with members
and clt and that will give you a real
robust and detailed picture of the work
that's been done by the ig project team
and also some reassurances around the
risk areas maps against council
objectives so hopefully
um that gives you a bit of a better
picture of what we've been doing in the
background since july
and in respect of the the data breaches
that we've had so far um and just
final thing for me really um is
around the idea of how many data
breaches have we
had um and what i have done is the ig
team have pulled together a report
and what i wanted to do today really was
just check with you all
what kind of things you would like to
see in that you know what detail and
what i would suggest is
it would take that away and it can then
um circulate that report which basically
will tell you how many data breaches
we've had compared to last year
it will give you a breakdown of what
types and what areas service areas those
those
data breaches are coming from and it
will also tell you
and the reason for those data breach so
for example you know i think the main
cause of date to reach or or um
source of data is people sending emails
to the wrong recipients or recipients
and
including data in there so we can give
you a breakdown of that if that would be
useful and we can certainly circulate
that after the meeting tonight
yeah thank you thanks for that just
our members covered by the i mean
obviously we can make data breaches but
our members i know we can have we've all
supposed to have done the gdp or
training and so on but
are we made aware it is very easy as you
say to pass on emails to somebody
without without looking down the list of
what what other information might be
you know you might get an email from an
officer explaining something that you
wouldn't want to
divulge to other people but it's very
easy to do that if you're
answering a lot of emails i just wonder
whether there was any guidance
provided to members about what we should
and should not
release to members of the public when
they contact us about matters which may
involve a third party which they're not
entitled
to know about but which you know which
we might know the background
but it is very you've got to be very
careful i think
not to really reveal information about
third parties to to somebody who might
be complaining to you
so i just wanted to whether any guidance
is provided to members
um yeah um i'm not i'm not sure what
obviously we we've all done the the the
online trainings up to
of data perception and that i'm sure
there's general warnings in there but
what we're proposing to do as part of
the id project is to do
an education and commons piece around
that so there's lots of new things that
we're
hoping to introduce that make perhaps
more simplified
around what little things that you can
do um
around you know you can also type a an
email address into your email and it
might just flick the wrong wrong email
in there there's a way you can actually
turn that off in your outlook to make
sure that you actually check in
your addresses each time so it's little
little
prompts like that and what we're
proposing to do is to do that for all
members and also for staff as well
so we're doing it back to basics these
are the basic things you know have a
think about your emails what's in there
check the email tray that type stuff
and so yeah we will be rolling that out
again um
and we're going to do some online
training as well to make that available
to everybody to
to take part in thanks so much
yeah i i agree i mean i think members
need to have an update on um
breaches of gdpr and it's very easy to
do
and you have to be care really careful
and i'm not sure there's an
understanding from members
exactly what happens if you do um
break the gdpr i know you can get heavy
fines
if it actually causes problems uh for
people
so i would welcome it but i think i have
done the gtbr
training because i think most of us have
you've got a high percentage
i believe it's just that sometimes it's
better if you have it
even if we have to have it by zoom at
the moment
because i think it's sort of um
it should be mandatory anyway and
secondly that i think
people perhaps get more out of an
interactive
um session and also the other thing is
like the case studies that we're
discussing at a previous
one without breaking any breaches i
think that's
quite a good way of showing how things
can be
um as it can show as an example of what
what happens
because i i you know i know that you can
be fined
or the organization can find a lot of
lots and lots of money but is that
generally
um known if you like
there's a recognition that there's a
slight disconnect to the online training
that we've all done in terms of gdpr the
mandatory one
and um it doesn't really make it real
for everybody you know myself included
um it doesn't really
register with your everyday practices
and and and so there's a recognition
really that we need to bridge that gap
and make some
um make some click give some player
guidance and training around
um with examples and workshops around
look how does this apply and you know
we've lots of ways in which we can do
that perhaps for
you know the social care team and the
legal team and break it down a little
bit further so we'll look at whether we
can do something
separate for members but really is just
that walking through really
just to just to flag up through your
everyday processes that you probably
don't realize you're doing just say you
know
perhaps you could do this in a different
way
yeah thanks very much i can't see
anybody else's
hand oh yes jenny jenny
clarification regarding you said
the breaches around addresses and emails
is it just that it is you know human
error
um or lack of training rather than any
of the data that the council
um has on databases etc that's incorrect
or is it kind of a combination you know
the two
um in both of the data breaches that
were reported to you it was human error
okay thank you thanks
thank you judith again
you muted judy sorry and i understand it
yeah it is
um perhaps human error and but the
other thing is um i'm not sure
uh people understand about emails
copying
emails and things like that only from
what i can observe myself if you see
what i mean
and that that duty is quite um
it severe really and the consequences
and okay it it may not matter
in there but it could matter um a
breach of data that could cause
potential problems
for for um either officers or counselors
or
the person who's actually complaining as
well
um i can say i i can foresee if you like
problems
with that i mean i have somebody who i
cannot pass on his emails
even if i ask permission because he's in
danger from
from somebody if you see what i'm uh
if you see what i mean yeah
yeah okay well thanks for that i can't
see any other
the other hands up thanks dominique
you've uh
got something to take away there i think
and something that we could all learn
from
in the future thanks for that so we're
going to item nine which is the
20 19 20 accounts which i think
graham bentley is going to deal with
yes thanks chair um obviously
we've heard um the opinion from the
audit completion report and the status
that that's in
um i think i'd just i'd just like to
start
by just giving some facts about the type
of organization but i think
we're highly complex organization we
spend
probably in the region of half a billion
pounds gross budget
our assets are running at just over 800
million pounds
so i think this complexities there and
um
and in terms of obviously the companies
that the council is now
part of we're now consolidating those
companies into our accounts as well
um those companies are things like the
joint ventures
that we have with bruntwood around
stratford mall the stamford quarter
the k site in old trafford
and also the trafford leisure community
interest company so
i think i think i just want to put into
perspective the
the task that we have done remotely this
year
in a normal year those accounts are
exceedingly difficult
um this year working remotely is a
massive achievement both
to the teams who've done it our finance
teams and also to karen's team to karen
tommy
and the rest of their team just to get
us to this stage now
um i think just an observation that i
have is that
what we're finding as an authority and
what i need to manage is that
the longevity that this process has
taken we're not normally sat at the end
of november
trying to get the account signed off
that september
that then gives you clear sight on
looking at budget and looking at
accounts preparation for the following
year
we're now near christmas and we're still
doing the accounts and i'm i'm keen
and i'll try and support karen and the
rest of the teachers to see if we can
nip it in the butt and get the sign off
as soon as we can
um i know we have the training
on the accounts once we put prior to
putting the accounts on deposit in july
um so i'm not going to run through the
accounts you'd be glad to know i think
just one or two headlines that i'd just
like to bring to the
committee's attention um in those
accounts
um the movement on council reserves
showed an increase of approximately 90
million
um during 1920 moving from 72 million to
91 million
what's what's happened there is that
obviously
increases in reserves is good news um we
did receive
for example the right at the tail end of
the year some significant funding
um around corvid obviously the impact of
corvid had started in march and the
government were releasing some grants at
that stage
so they sat on the balance sheet as
reserves at year end
of other items during 1920 that added to
reserves were things like the
contributions we made
from the income we were generating from
our investment strategy the asset
investment strategy so
we were putting monies into reserve
to mitigate against any risks on the
asset investment strategy that we've got
there are also increases in some of our
capital reserves we
we have some reserves that support the
capital program
and if if some of our big schemes end up
slipping and not completing on time for
whatever reason
those monies to fund those schemes sit
on the balance sheet
so we did see an increase in reserves
on on our asset side of things there was
an increase of just over 140 million
pound on our assets
what what that stems from is our
investment through the capital program
so we spend on our fixed assets we spend
on our schools and on our highways
so that adds to our asset values
and we've also been incurring
expenditure on the asset
investment strategy
and the different um opportunities that
have come along in that so that's the
reason why our assets have gone up
uh to to offset some of that we're
seeing an increase in some of our
long-term liabilities particularly
around our borrowings
and the monies that we've borrowed from
the public works loans board
just on a couple of other issues there's
some aspects of the accounts
that are termed the collection fund so
that's basically an
update on our council tax and business
rates
position um and what we're seeing
is particularly around business rates is
this pressure starting
and you see pressures for example what
i'm talking about is reductions in the
relatable values of some of our
properties
what we saw during the year for example
was
properties that used to be on our
business rates
uh within our tax base for business
rates or commercial properties
being converted knocked down and
residential units being provided
an example of that's just down the road
from the town hall at the old
itron site so we have seen an erosion to
some extent
on business rates and now the extent
that corvid continues that in
2021 and beyond is something that we're
watching like a hawk
the simple reason that business rates
income
is pretty crucial to us um
so i don't want to pick up on any other
points in the accounts obviously other
than to say
um we will endeavor to get the
outstanding issues
agreed with karen we were seeking we
would normally get approval from the
audit committee
this evening but obviously what we're
looking at now is just to get a
delegation to the chair
and to uh corporate director finance and
systems to sign those accounts office
as soon as possible hopefully monday um
so other than that i think that's that's
my update there chair
thanks graeme any questions
in the hands can we
approve that report then and delegate to
myself and the corporate director i
think before the end of november
to uh sign them off is that uh agreed
can you do them by monday i don't know
that's uh
that's up to date isn't it that's got to
be done
yeah i'm looking
i'm looking for great oh so i can see
sorry check karen do
if if we moved beyond mundy
we moved beyond mundidormy i think i'd
just like to i think
it's fair to say again trafford's not
alone i think
it's probably fair to say that there's
other manchester districts where
the audits and the sign-offs been
prolonged and i think in some cases that
might be new year
i would i would not like to think we're
going to the new year whether we can
achieve
the end of november hopefully it will be
slightly after if
if that was the case i don't think
that's an issue karen if we go beyond
the
deadline as such is it no so so the
council complies with its
statutory responsibilities if on the day
of the
mhclg deadline which is the 30th uh you
put a notice on your website to say that
you haven't published your audited
accounts because the audit is still
ongoing
and at that point you are um you are
compliant with the legislation as it
were
and we will get signed off as soon as we
can i am hopeful
that we can do it by monday but i'm not
100 certain i'm probably only about
60 70 certain it's doable by monday but
i would
be fairly confident that it won't go off
very much longer after that
the big the real big challenge is that
is the timeliness of those bankwesters
coming back
we asked for them in july and they're
still not with us um now
so we are doing what we can and we will
move it along as quickly as we can
so so should sorry judith gone
rooted you muted judith
so you want agreement and um
for the accounts to be moved uh um
[Music]
for that to be moved to monday to to
um to delegate sorry yeah yeah
yeah oh as or as soon as possible
afterwards
i was going to say if we left it open
ended rather than just say
delegated till monday because
technically after monday
i would be delegated to me would it so
is it i believe it's open-ended yeah
just say delegate
to the chair and the corporate director
to approve obviously as soon as possible
yeah i'll move that then
yeah that's okay can we all agree to
that
well thanks very much yeah we'll try for
monday but obviously
there's some slight doubt about that but
it will be as soon as possible
okay well thanks very much for that i
just
lost my agendas holding it right so the
next item is the uh
is the uh item 10 insurance performance
report i think that's you again graham
dave morgridge is going to take that one
today
right thank you um just this is an
annual
report just to update uh members in
terms of the activity that's taking
place in the
insurance looking at the cost insurance
the number of types of claims we've had
and then looking forward looking looking
at the achievements and some of the
outlook
um just to give give a flavor of it the
the insurance budget um it's made up
from
um fairly simple budget basically it's
premiums
uh we pay for to the insurance companies
um provision for for claims basically
we cover ourselves um for the first um
an excess amount between 250 and 275
000 pounds and alex one of the report
gives you the details of the type of
insurance that recovered from property
employer liability public liability um
and the the amounts of cover that we are
we take insurance out for
so public liability for instance we've
covered up to 50 million pound
and the there's an excess within within
that that you would have on your motor
insurance policy that you cover the
first amount
so in order to keep premiums low we
cover excesses ourselves
between 250 275
000 uh depending on the type of the type
of cover
so the budget is made up from from the
premiums we paid the insurance cover
uh the provisions for those elements
that we're actually self-insuring for
and certain amounts we don't actually
take insurance premium out for
uh something like property losses we
cover those ourselves from scratch
and then we recharge income out to
schools
and the dso and the trading arms of the
council
so the actual overall budget for the for
the um
insurance was 753 000 pound
uh the actual came in at 466. so we
underspent
about 287 000 and that went into the
general
council via uh under spending the year
end
uh we saved um money on insurance
premiums went out to tender
um in april 2019
uh the the term the markets at the time
was um uh fairly uh
generous so we managed to actually
reduce our premiums by 116 000
um provision for claims were actually
we set aside um uh the provision for
claims we underspent about 175
000 on that one because we've i've seen
a number
reduction in certain types of claims
um and then the income from schools and
like so that was slightly
slightly better off june of 36. um
so in terms of how we set us up we've
set aside
insurance money for full claims over the
past and historic claims and that's
called an insurance provision that sits
on our balance sheet
uh to cover the uh anticipated
costs of those claims and also the
claims that we've yet to receive that
we're likely to receive
uh based on previous past experience and
so we've set aside a total value of
just over three million three point one
six two million pound
and the year ended 31st of march that's
reviewed on a on a biannual basis
uh actually looks at that looks at
previous claims in the likes of that so
they they
that that value is deemed sufficient to
cover
the claims that we've set aside already
and expecting future claims
and we also hold an insurance risk
reserve
um this this basically covers
um any fluctuation in the budget during
the year
and also if we have a number of high
value claims that hit us in any
particular year
we we can draw off that reserve and
as part of the general budget review
closed down and also during the
preparation the budget we analyze all
the reserves
we hold and we say with the sufficient
to cover the risk
um we deemed that we we needed to keep
an insurance reserve of about 1.9
million
pound and that wasn't logical the basis
that we would
cover ourselves up to three to four
large insurance claims where we have to
cover the excess between 250 275
000 so roughly a million pound on there
and we still have potential exposure to
claims under the municipal
mutual insurance um framework that was
set up
um so we would we think we still
potentially claims
uh available for that so we keep 500 000
available for that
and then general amount 400 to cover any
fluctuation in the budget
for insured losses um so
so at the year end the in table two
you'll see that
the balance in the provision was
increased from 3 million 30 to 3 million
162
and the insurance reserve roughly kept
about the same level
1.9 million and in terms of claim
activity
uh we've actually seen a reduction in
claims
in into 2019 20
um both in the amount of uh
volume of claims and also the financial
amount that we paid out
and the the volumes largely reduced
because of the
the actual highway claims uh had had
reduced in 1920
um we had an increase in 1819 because it
was a poor win to the beast from the
east
a lot of pothole claims in the likes of
that so we've seen an improvement
comparison from from 1819
um in terms of the overall uh claims
profile
that that's detailed in in annex 2
it splits over the different tabs claims
employer liability
highway injury highway property
um the employer liability
generally fairly consistent um there's
only four claims
in in last year we tend not to have many
employed liability claims was largely
office based
um we've transferred a lot of the higher
risk areas when we were
through the amy contract for most
frontline services on that one
um we do have one outstanding high value
claim
there 163 000 pounds
um and it it it's
looking from the in the current
financial year we're getting
advice that would probably be able to
defend that claim successfully
so that will release that provision from
from there
um hiring his injury claims again fairly
consistent these are trips and slips
from uh bottles and the likes of that on
the pavement
um the howard property you've already
mentioned that
there's that's been a reduction um of
quite a generous reduction from compared
to previous years
and generally because we've not had such
a harsh winter
and we've had resources coming from the
pothole funding which is repaired
and maintained the highways um
we are seeing a bit of an increase in in
tree liability claims
um not massive amounts but say for
instance in 2015
34 is crept up to about 54.
and we are looking at reviewing the
reasons for that i think
some of the principles that we we're
hearing is that a lot of the tree
more mature trees obviously planted in
victorian days
they're actually now probably getting
big enough now to start causing damage
to pavements and driveways and things
like that so
we are actually having a good um a free
liability review
in the current year just to understand
that and making sure we've got policies
and procedures in place
uh to defend those and the public
liability claims
this is these are probably the bigger
ticket items
um we're seeing the general increase in
those as there's more
um cases higher profile cases going
through the court of appeal
and human rights the these within within
there
we've got um within the total estimated
um
provision we've got just four cases
totaling up to 559 000
two of those the data breach cases that
we've already discussed
they came in during the year so there's
provisions set aside for those
um in terms of defense rates we we're
still
you know high defense rates overall 71
percent um
you know the top end 91 for employees
liability
uh the tree the trees have already
mentioned 58
um the way trees are taught the treated
under the law of tor
um that means the council um the
it's harder to defend those those cases
than they would do as a highway
claim um so again
it's still a fairly high decent defense
rate at 58
so in terms of the the outlook um
and achievements um looking forward um
the local government mutual was set up
um
we were one of the founding members of
it and the idea was to set up a mutual
so it can be
with with private the the insurance
market to drive down
premium rates and insurance premiums
and it wasn't it wasn't actually found
in the town when we went out to tender
for our previous um
uh quotation tender for insurance so we
couldn't actually ride on the back of it
and the leader of the council uh is one
of the board of directors on it
i think that they're trying to look at
themselves and trying to turn itself
reflecting trying to
re release themselves we're keeping a
watch in brief of it
potentially when when we go out to
tender again
in three or four years time we could
bend it right on the back of that one um
in terms of the insurance market overall
it's been quite a tough year
i think we're aware of the the the
issues about grenfell
um and some of the um the weather
issues with with global warming uh
impacting on us
so we're actually obviously keeping an
eye on that for potential future
impacts on long-term uh quotations at
the moment we have locked in
for for the recent tender exercise so
it's not so much of a problem for us at
the moment
um covering 19 um again not
not much of a major issue for us i mean
um
many companies are not cool that didn't
take out pandemic cover
um our business disruption has obviously
been
supported with with the resources we've
been getting through
uh for so far for supporting kovid and
there's not a major issue there's about
13 claims to date largely
related to travel disruption costs for
schools
uh again not massively in terms of high
value an average cost of a thousand
pounds and the insurance renewal
we said with this in 1920 we did see
reduction in in the premiums
some of the things we're finding out
with the experience in in particular
public liability claims
may impact on on the insurance premium
in in the current finance next financial
year so
we're watching that making sure that we
can negotiate those down to a minimum
and then lastly the the cyber and data
risk um
it's it's still a fairly immature market
in terms of actually
um defining
a suitable policy premium for cyber
cover
um the premiums are still fairly high
but we're looking
you know in the region of um sixty
thousand pound when we went out to
tender
versus the risk of it we do
carry elements of cyber cover within our
existing
um insurance liabilities for instance
the data breach
uh side of things if it if it results in
public injury
um then you can actually claim within
within
those elements of your existing
insurance policy um
there's not many councils and about 15
percent of councils actually do take out
specific cyber cover
um we're in the process of
reviewing what the options are and
potentially going out to market again to
see
if see if those uh tended the quotations
are already
we can firm up on those um so that's
about it from from my side
thanks dave any questions anybody
rose because of thompson
thank you a quick one about uh employers
liability
because absolutely everybody's been
affected by this and we're all working
in completely different ways now
a lot of working from home a lot working
with ppe
does our employers liabilities that's
still fit
for purpose does it still cover people
working from home
um or does it need looking at how does
it work
if we're working in different ways and
yeah and i suppose as a as an
organization we want legal obligation
that we
we do undertake risk assessments um
for all both office based and uh and
home-based staff and
i think that that's something that we um
we need to demonstrate that we're
maintaining those standards
um and i know that there are there are
activities
and and self-assessments that go on to
make sure
that people are when they're working
from home the environment's right
your setups right in the likes of that
and
so it's um i suppose it's something to
be aware of that there are
potential exposure to the council
for an increase in future claims for
that
um and and i suppose that's the nature
of the insurance
market that that one the the reaction to
how
we've assessed that risk and adapted to
that risk
would feed through to whether there's
been a
negligence maybe that would result in an
increase in premiums and then obviously
the cycle then gets tightened up again
okay thank you okay councilor collins
thank you i just wanted to ask a little
bit more about the tree liability review
so
are these um about cases where say a big
just a little street picture sorry a big
heavy branch falls on a car or something
and the council has to then pay for
damage to the
um perhaps something like that is that
the sort of case you're talking about
yeah so
i think there's there's been a couple of
cases that
i've seen seen recently where um the
highway
tree had disrupted the payment and also
then
disrupted the driveway so there was
um as i said these claims are
particularly difficult
to um to defend because
the tree's doing what a tree doesn't and
it grows and the thing
it's um it's an assessment of we've done
all we can to make sure that the
the damage the trees caused is it caused
by the tree and i think
these the difficulties that um
we can we we couldn't come across in
this type of plane the very difficult
to to to to defend um
so i think the ones where you you would
see
a falling branch that would be probably
part of the same
um the same activity and again proving
that you you've done in regular
inspections and
that you you've you've got a cyclical
like some maintenance cycle and the
likes of that
um but i think we can probably put some
more update during the year this this is
that
it's it's evolving now not just for
trafford but it seems to be coming
across
across the country i think you've got
you start scratching your heads
why is it starting to to develop and i
suppose
you look at um and i know
mum and dad where they live it was uh
that the road's starting to ripple a bit
you think there's houses that were
probably built in the 1950s
that and now the trees that were planted
them are getting into like quite sizable
mature trees that are causing an impact
on pavements and driveways and the likes
of that
so hopefully we as i say we're doing
this uh
review with with the tree collards in
the tree department just to understand
whether our processes are right so
hopefully we can perhaps do some
more updates on that and put some more
uh context to it
both for ourselves and for you as well
and um
if we're looking at the the financial
impact the negative financial impacts of
the trees are we looking at the positive
financial impacts of the trees so the
health benefits
absolutely yes no absolutely i mean i
think that's one of the things that
uh the health benefit obviously the
degree in gender and the importance of
the environment you know i think from
during the lockdown the the the feedback
and appreciation from from the
from the green environment is so so
critical for
health and well-being so it's definitely
something that so would feed into that
um you know obviously to keep the trees
in
in good condition and make sure that
they they can be there for the future
okay thanks very much i can't
chris are you singling oh i'm sorry yes
mr chairman i'm signaling
yeah um yeah i'm just i'm gonna pick up
on three things that
the tree issue is becoming enormous and
it's not trees that are 50 years old
there's trees that are 100 years old in
some instances
i mean it's trees outside houses that
were built in the 1920s
they're 100 years old now and some of
them are looking at one this morning
with one of uh you know an amy
chap it's enormous and the damage that
it's starting
not just to people's driveways is to our
stuff yes not just our footpaths it's
our roads
it's doing damage to as well you know so
and much as i much as i like trees
uh there comes a point when basically
trees have a life
you know it doesn't matter ashley you
know there's no silver birch has got a
life
a beach has got a life it's about god
knows how much times longer and sweet
chestnut will last a thousand years
but you know that it is a big big
problem that is coming
and it's in obviously in certain parts
of the borough where
buildings took place at certain times
and certain trees were
planted at certain times but picking up
on two other things back to the
employer's liability there i mean
and home working in the health and
safety
work et cetera et cetera it dictates
that
the the employer has just as much
responsibility
to provide things that are under health
and safety executive
uh for someone working at home as they
do as if they're working in an office
and we all know that we see people
working at home
on a laptop that's probably honest
sitting on a settee
or they're not or that kitchen table or
something like that
i mean i've always worried about school
children bending over laptops because
that doesn't do their posture any good
at all
but i just go on to say that when i
where i worked which was what
it was in the insurance industry and it
was a company that employed 57 000
people internationally and when we all
moved on to using
the visual display units
that's when one of the two things that
they only ever asked and said people
must do arrived and what it was
was an online interactive questionnaire
training
about the use of the vdu and the people
that didn't do
it got a reminder and if they didn't do
it they got a second reminder and if
they then didn't do it they got a notice
that they didn't do it by the end of
31st of march that year
they would have terminated their
employment
that's how serious the company took
people working in those in that
situation
and i just do worry likely has been
expressed
about a lot of employees not just ours
obviously
working all over the country now with
the idea they're going to spend half the
time working from home so it is that
serious
uh finally the point i was going to say
is i might have missed this and i'm
not quite sure but i sort of caught it
when you meant you mentioned the beast
from the east
what what connection was that in in
terms of
the year in which you're talking about
in
2018 when the it was yeah but i mean
it wasn't in relation to the year which
we're talking about 2000. oh no sorry no
in 2018
we had an increase in highway injury and
problems we just it was just i heard it
and i thought oh yeah
that's not the year we're in at the
moment no no
no there was a drop in 1920 and one of
the reasons why
because we had the beast because 18 19
was sort of
thanks very much thank you yeah okay
geraldine you still got your hand up is
that just left over yeah
okay i can't see anybody else's oh alan
are you
signaling no okay
thanks very much dave that's a very
useful report there
so we go on to um item 11
treasury management and i've got you
down
this scream known to you yes thanks
chair yeah
um just by way of a brief overview on
the treasury management report
the committee will be aware that would
bring three reports each year
to the committee the first one is the
strategy report
which comes as part of the overall
package of budget reports and that's
done
in the new year in january early
february
this is the mid-year report from that
strategy we'll also do an out-turn
report
so i just think in terms of
some of the key issues within the report
i think what we've seen in the last six
months is the impact to corvid
and what has that done it's just worth
mentioning that that
economy wise obviously there's been
massive pressures on the economy
the bank of england reduced its base
rates
which has a bearing on on our activity
and the returns that we do get from it
but it's obviously worth saying that
when we're looking at investing our
surplus cash the return
is in effect the third priority
the first two priorities always reside
with the security of the investments
and the liquidity of the investments so
what i mean by that is
when we look at our cash flow we need to
make sure we can meet our obligations
when they fall due in the short
and long term so um
so whilst we're seeing in a reduction in
rate the the other issue that we were
concerned with
on corvid and its impact was around
the levels of cash we were holding and
what we were seeing in
march early april was
significant pressures on our expenditure
and i'll come on to that on the next
item around the
around the monitoring reports but
significant pressures on expenditure
supporting the social care market and
amongst other things
and also significant pressure on our
income
so what that was doing was was was put
in pressure we saw that putting pressure
on our cash
the levels of cash we had government
um did react to that um and we lobbied
that obviously they reimbursed councils
ideally up front for some of the
measures that we had to put in place
david wright mentioned earlier about the
significant amount of business grants
that we processed
in april and may about 50 million
approaching 50 million pounds
um so we were just mindful of cash flow
at the time
so i think what we do with this report
um which we've started to put an
executive
summary in the report which is on page
29.
just a couple of key points from that in
terms of what's happened
in terms of some of our investments our
investments
the volume of investments has fallen
from 106 million at the start of the
year to 62.
whilst kobe has had a slight impact on
that and it but it's not major
i think the big item there was the fact
that the council
in the first quarter of the year paid an
advanced pension payment to
greater manchester pension fund and that
was in respect
of the employer contributions towards
the pensions of staff
so rather than make the pension
contributions each year
what we've done in the last um few years
is make those pension contributions in
advance
and that has the benefit that it gives
the authority a reduced pension
contribution rate
um so there's benefit to paying in
advance but it it's
it's a cash flow item for us in that it
takes cash away in the short term
in terms of debt our debts increased
from 377 million at the start of the
year
to just over 400
the reason that that's increased is
basically debt that's been required to
support the capital program and the
asset investment strategy
but that's been in line with the plans
that we had for them
just in terms of a couple of other
issues within the report
the treasury management function is
quite very tightly governed
and we do produce numerous indicators
that we call prudential indicators and
other risk indicators
and it's i'll just put to the committee
that based on the monitoring we've done
none of those indicators have been
breached in the first half of the year
just in terms of budget um one of the
things that
has impacted on the treasury management
budget and again i'll come on to it in
the next item is the
with budget within our treasury
management area for the airport
dividends
so that's something and that's a
casualty of corvid that we won't be
getting that
in 2021 probably 21 22 and the year
after
so that's that's one of the in-ear
budget pressures that i'll
refer to in the in the following report
chair so
happy to take any questions thanks
thanks uh great many questions
can't see anybody's hands up there so
okay
got away with that thanks thanks for him
the next item is the item
12 the budget monitoring report is that
you are
mark i've forgotten who's going to do
that i'll do that again chair
yeah so this the budget monitor report
that you've got in front of you
is the um half year position so it's the
position as at the end of september
went to executive on um on monday
this week so
just to pick up on some of the key
issues obviously
as karen mentioned in her update on the
audit completion report
it doesn't seem two minutes ago since we
sat at council and set a balanced budget
since 2021 um
but what's happened then has had a
massive impact on the budget
so in terms of the impact of corvid
what we've seen is that our core with
pressures and that's
the impact on our expenditure um
the impact on sales fees and charges
income and the impact on
council tax and business rate receipts
would look in the current estimate for
the year the impact in the year is a
gross figure of 51.5 million
what we're doing with that is obviously
through
our relationships with clg and local
governments relationships with clg we're
reporting this
up our update positions monthly
and the government's reacted to that
with quite a number of different
grants and another support towards fees
and charges
and support towards some of our funding
issues
so taking those into account um our net
gap is about six and a half million
6.6 million pounds that's our projection
at the moment
in effect being the unfunded impact of
corvid
uh this year in terms of other aspects
of the budget
um what we have seen
is that we've got some underspending at
the moment
and that's particularly in the areas of
adult placement costs
and in respect to some of the children's
investments
that we were making into children
services staffing
so that's helping us out at the moment
and it and if that benefit
was to continue that would mean that the
overspend of 6.6 from corvid was reduced
to just over
200 about 220 000 pound what we're doing
at the moment and you'll see in the
report at paragraph eight i think it is
that
we're being slightly cautious so we are
trying to explain that the budget
position that there's a gap there's a
range so if everything goes well
we've probably been about 220 000
overspend but
i think there's still six months of risk
still to go through yet
um so
we're just being slightly cautious on
that what i would say is that
and this is what i look at is what
elements of contingency
remain still in those budget projections
and i'm comforted at this stage that we
do have contingency items
um within these projections
that if things deteriorated we have got
those to fall back on as well
um just in terms of other aspects of the
report we do
give an update on the capital programme
um
but there's not been much with one or
two um
small amounts of rephasing on a couple
of schemes into
into the next financial year um
obviously in terms of the overall
position and
we've got our eyes obviously looking at
the current financial year
but we've got a massive focus on 2122 so
we've
we've gone with the draft budget
proposals to uh
executive in october and
obviously not dwelling on what karen
said but the issue is the authority has
to make recurring savings
um so what we've done as
as part of the draft budget proposals i
think the figure's about 15 million
pound off
of recurring savings so what we're doing
at the moment is
um as part of our robustness checks on
the budget is looking at the business
cases behind them and testing the
assumptions behind those
um that's not to say that
we will achieve them all but i think
there's other things coming into play
and i
it's at this time of year that the
pieces of the jigsaw start fitting
together a bit in terms of the budget
you will have heard yesterday around the
spending round
um and there was some positive
reaction within the spending round that
should should
assist in in helping us balance
uh the 21 22 budget i think
we just need to put some caution on that
that it's early days we're not seeing
the detail behind some of these measures
but um i know from my point of view
some of the the messages were welcome
um have we not received them um
obviously would have been a far
difficult position than what i think we
will be that's not to say anything will
be easy for 21 22.
um so sorry just to deviate into 2122 it
was an update on 2021 but i thought it
was just worth mentioning
happy to take any questions chair
thanks sir can i just a small point
before we start on page
20 47 of our papers the revenue budget
in paragraph
2 it says the change to the net budget
will need to be formally approved and
considered by the full council in
november 2020
we're not now as understanding having a
council meeting on the 30th what's
that has been put back yeah we have
drafted the report last week and i think
it was only last week that we got told
it been pushed back a little bit but
it's just a marginal movement in the net
budget because of some additional
funding we got
um in the early part of the year
relating to public health
change but it will get approved at the
capitol early
who was it oh hi hi barry because the
wind stanley
ah thanks sure um again thanks for the
report graham
managing to summarize all those pages
into
three or four minutes fantastic um
just a a question on
uh central government contribution and
the amounts of money we're out of pocket
because i get very confused unless
you're back to there yet
seeing all the different all the
different pots of money which you've
been doing this and do that remind
through the conversation now with sky tv
yesterday talking about my
my renewal all i want to know about how
much you're gonna cost me per month i'm
not bothered about the discounts here
and the amount of money there
so well you you said that the
in the 2021 the pressure is 51.5 million
that was the combination and then there
was a gap of 6.6 million
is that like the steady state without
using reserves from last year or without
the savings generated elsewhere because
that then drops down to 220
000 so i'm trying to work out whether
they
that that gap of six point six minutes
being removed by us but by
the clever things and savings or whether
that gap still remains
just does that question make sense
totally yeah it's
just in terms of a breakdown on page 65
of the report there is a table
which basically starts off showing what
that
gap of 55 is and showing the different
funding streams we've got
so the six and a half is a real gap
in terms of the pressures caused by
covid
but what we've put under that table is
that
within other aspects of the budget
what i would call business as usual
there are some business as usual
underspends at this stage
um and if i said uh
it is quite morbid around adult social
care clients and
reductions around obviously because of
the deaths um
so that so we've seen underspent in some
of those areas now
we just need to be cautious that
if we get additional pressures coming
between now and the end of the year
it might impact on these businesses as
usual underspends we've got
which might mean we might be nearer to
six and a half million but what i do say
is that
each and every month we submitted
returns to government so we'll be
submitting the next one
dave knows about this because the
returns are huge
the amount of detail they're asking on
this and we'll be saying that we've got
unfunded pressures
manchester will stop but will and
everybody else is
so with the fair wind
there's potential that we will get
additional government support between
now and year end
as well um but obviously we're not
predicting that at the moment
yeah so in essence it's just the the
funding app is not
i've got to say is lucky that's not the
right word to use at all it's um
fortuitous that we've got let's try
to avoid that as well you know what
generating it but it's it's it's kind of
it's
it's it's almost a phasing saving isn't
it because of the
the reduction in services which we we
intended to um
which ordinarily we'd have we have to
fund
um i mean i see like the loss of the
dividend this is nearly five and a half
million quid isn't it from
the airport yeah so within the fifty one
and a half million
yes five knots yeah and whilst
governments have said
we will help support some of your
reductions in sales fees and charges
what government said is if it's a
reduction that relates to you losing
income on a commercial activity
you've taken that decision to go that
way yourself so we will
not support you for those and the
airport falls into that category
unfortunately
all right all right no it's not at all
clear is it it's not
this is gonna
i think there's still plenty of
uncertainty but
like i say yesterday the spending round
gave
some positive news for us
[Music]
all right thank you okay okay thanks
anybody else
oh yes this is black
i'm going to ask a more general question
regarding
the amount of faces and the amount of
savings
on the personnel side and we've seen
that kind of year and years
just from the time i've i've been with
you and i understand that obviously some
of it is
a few vacancies that haven't been filled
some of it's obviously
work that isn't going ahead due to
what's happening at the moment
is it a continual kind of theme so
obviously
there's always going to be a sizable you
know saving because these posts
aren't ever going to be filled um
it's just to understand how the the
budgeting happens you know is it
obviously do intensive to fill the post
but you know there's different things
that
come into play that prohibit this you
know
yeah i it's a good question i think what
we need to be mindful of and when you
when
we do see underspends on staffing and we
do see that every year because we have
to budget for our staffing cost
but it's the impact on the staff that
are left over
and people are mindful of that but in
terms of budgeting we both
we budget for our establishment in some
areas where we see high turnover
and we do see that maybe in things like
our transactional services
might be an example that we do budget
for what we call a vacancy factor so we
budget for the fact that we may have a
little turnover and some
little downtime in some of the posts
until we can get new recruits in um
[Music]
but i i think they understand this year
is not
it's not necessarily out of kill to
where we've been in previous years
okay thank you thank you
okay i can't see any other hands going
up
so thanks for that uh graham i think the
next thing is the uh
item 13 or an insurance service update
which i think
definitely is mark before that can i
just say
i've had a slight indication about the
timing um
i'm not i mean it's important i think we
get through all this but
we've been going for two hours and i
think technically
we're supposed to limit the time but
carry on
i'll um
so in terms of this audit and assurance
updates um the committee
received a copy um of the audit plan
previous meeting um and this is an
update of actual work we've done in the
first half of the year
um there's a summary there on page
78 section three sort of our main areas
of focus and section four
some of the outcomes from the work um
i have to say the the plan was produced
prior to the march lockdown
um and since then uh significant time
has been spent on other areas and other
priorities
really supporting the council's covert
19 responses
as david wright mentioned at the start
uh we've worked with with his team
um sort of aligned with the sort of work
we'd expected to do but not our usual
work
um in carrying out helping carrying out
checks around the
the grant payments being made um
so that was around the small business
grant fund and also the
the retail hospitality and leisure grant
um
but we also work with the strategic
growth team as well
around the discretionary grants and and
had some input into that and provided
challenge in terms of the payments being
made
um so there has been significant time in
that area but having said that we've
tried
where we can as well as sort of the more
business as usual planned work
um in doing that as well obviously
taking into account any impact of code
with 19
and so for instance the treasury
management review we did
we were looking at the procedures
adopted in terms of the
remote working and any any changes from
that
so in terms of the actual audit reports
we got out
um there were 15 final reports and one
draft report issued
um all of the opinion levels and
for those of you new to the committee
appendix 3 on page 89
provides an explanation of those levels
but they were all basically me
at least medium or better opinion levels
and in each case there was an agreed
action plan
agreed by management to address any
recommendations made
um page 79
starts a list there of all the different
audit reports we got out
in the period um so you see there's a
range of audit reviews covering
key financial systems i t audit reviews
uh procurement reviews there's also
quite a bit of follow-up
work there following up reviews from the
previous year
and it also includes in the listing
partnership
work we've done through the star shared
service where stockport produced one of
the reports as well
further on to that page 81
as well as the reports issued uh section
six
covers summarizes um other work we've
done in the period so as well as the
grants work
um the work around the strategic risk
register
and also the national fraud initiative
um the new
exercise for that's coming on this year
where we have to submit data
to the cabinet office um which we're in
the middle of at the moment
um and it does include covet 19 grants
information as well
so with the david's fraud team
they'll be work going on through into 21
as well following up on any potential
issues around payments
being made um we also um
provided some support um around the
annual governance statement to legal
services doing a draft review
of the documents and working with them
on that um just moving on to section
seven
of the report uh this is the impact of
audit work
um report there all recommendations we
made from those 15 reports were all
accepted which
which was pleasing for the period um
and also in terms of follow-up work we
did
um the table in section five that just
just described that included five
follow-up audits
and in addition to that we request
information from managers on on progress
so we also there was worthington primary
school we asked for an update and it was
all recommendations were accepted uh
and were implemented and we've got
several other follow-up pieces of work
in progress as at the end of september
so for the next committee update i'll be
able to
to uh update you on a number of other
follow-up
audits um and also i'll provide a
summary analysis up to the end of
december
in terms of percentages of
recommendations that have been
implemented or in progress
etc um
performance against the plan obviously
and as other um officers have indicated
times have
not been as we'd have anticipated them
to be
um we have in terms of audit days spent
broadly in line with what we expected to
do so four six one days spent against
450 planned
um but there are some variations in some
of the
the categories of work and so the the
work around the covid grants
has taken up a significant amount of
time
similarly there's other areas that we
haven't spent as much time as we'd
originally planned i mean a good example
of that was school audits
where there were a number of school
audits planned during the summer
that we agreed to delay until later in
the year
we have started to pick up that work now
and doing a number of remote
audits of schools um similarly another
other service areas there's been some
delays to that work and some of the in
some cases at the request of services
you know due to the current situation um
just in terms of the targets for
producing reports we have 38 target 38
reports for the year as a target
at the halfway stage i suppose you'd
expect roughly 19
well we're up to 15 and we had seven
other pieces of work in progress
so we may find by the year end we're a
little less than target it's a bit
difficult to say at this moment
but clearly changes in priorities of
influence that
um finally section nine
just summarizes planned work we've got
at the moment october to december the
work underway
um and appendix 2 provides a listing of
the various audit reports planned and
you'll be able to see there
areas of work we've completed and areas
of work planned
there are a number of audits there
saying timing to be greed
we're going to be working over the next
few months with each of the corporate
directors to agree
which work goes on now which we need to
consider for twenty one two
uh and and or obviously authorities as
well priorities changing with
with the kerbin 19 situation um but
happy to take any questions uh on that
report
thanks thanks mark i better declare an
interest in willington primary school
since you mentioned that because i'm a
governor there
and non-pecuniary interests yeah any
any questions to mark on that
no i can't see any hands going up okay
thanks for that so we're going to item
14 which is a strategic risk register
that's you again mark i think okay
thanks chair yeah um so it's a further
update to
the committee you had one at the the
last meeting in july
um there's been another exercise
recently um
where audits is supported clt in
updating the
the risk register so the report provides
an update
on that i suppose the key thing to
mention in terms of any changes
updates um but one risk has been added
to the register since the last meeting
around the climate emergency i know it's
a topic that was actually discussed
by the committee at the last meeting no
counsellor coggins
raised on that um clt have been
reviewing
uh that area and you see details in risk
too
around that risk um
on page 93 is just a summary table there
in terms of the risk levels
um so you'll see where the number of
high ones in there
currently 16 strategic risks listed
um main detail from page 94 onwards for
each risk
um also as mentioned the last meeting
about and now
the way it's analyzed so we've we've
added some columns there to
show the breakdown of the risk or
counselor boys raise that
last time so we've got impact and
likelihood scores actually shown there
um in terms of the risks obviously there
remains a number of authority-wide
issues a number of
specific service-wide issues covert 19
there's risk one but also impacts around
covered 19 and described
across a number of the risk areas listed
there
um each risk has an assigned owner
who is providing the updates and the
committee will continue to get further
updates
so in the final quarter of the year
there will be another one
coming to the committee it includes
there an update on information
governance which
uh dominique described earlier shows
that the updates around the that area as
well
again happy to take any questions thanks
i think
uh councillor coggins
yes thanks chair um and thanks mark and
those of you who
have made this update it's um it's very
welcome
to see that we've acknowledged the
climate emergency as a risk
formally and i i i was surprised that it
got rated
with an impact of four out of five i i
do wonder what you have to do to have an
impact of five out of five
um in this in this context but that's a
separate question
um i had a few questions which um i
realized we're running out of time so we
can take these them
off offline and discuss by email perhaps
if
um about the approach of taking
adaptation as primary so
how we can deal with the mess um and
mitigation is secondary
how we can stop the mess from happening
i would have thought that from a risk
point of view
we would as a general approach want to
stop the bad thing happening
and secondarily insofar as we can stop
the happening
and adapt to to to to to to meet
to meet that fact uh rather than the
other way around that seems to be
indicated here
um and i suppose as well um talks about
the risk
as being about extreme weather whereas
of course the impacts are are going to
be
much much wider going to impact our our
food system our financial system and
and so on and so those are my thoughts
but yes
um really great to see that it has
popped on there and i said we can now
always discuss by email um yeah happy
happy to feed on points as well through
to the next clt review
thanks very much any other hands up i
can't see any any there
okay thanks for that mark so we've gone
now to uh
uh work the work programme which i think
against you marketing yeah that that's
fairly simple one there just shows the
the details from the first two meetings
and
the remaining two we have in february
march yeah it does include cyber
security
update as one of the strategic risks so
that probably at the february meeting
but certainly at one of the next two
meetings we'll have an update on that
yeah thanks for that any questions no
we agree the work program item 16
urgent business i'm not aware of any uh
joe and no
no not aware of any chair no no well
that's the the end of the meeting we've
we've just exceeded the time it's only
slightly i thought it was important
we carry on anyway hopefully next time
we might be meeting in person though i
doubt if we're talking february but
perhaps
too optimistic but uh perhaps the one
after that maybe
okay well thanks everybody for their
attendance and uh
see you at least virtually again at the
council meeting
thanks really bye thanks chad
hi i'll just i'll close the recording
for you chair and then if i could just
have a very quick word with you
uh when we close the recording after the
meeting yeah